Here are the three best niches to write
and sell for forever. Never have to
change is health, wealth, and
relationships. And there's micro niches
and micro markets inside of all of
those. So you can niche down. Let's say
I wanted to write for the health niche.
Well, in health, there's nutrition,
there's exercise, there's weight loss,
there's all kinds of things like that.
And then you can niche down even
further. I can do nutrition for
athletes. And then you can niche down
even further. I can do animal-based diet
for athletes. And then if you want, you
can niche down even further. You could
say animal-based diet for runners. The
further that you niche down until you
own your entire niche is the best place
to start writing. But as long as it's
tethered to health, wealth, or
relationships, you're good to